i'm worried about the kids who get this
the teenagers who get maligned as awful
bigots racists
xenophobes transphobes just for having
an opinion that
may not go with the you know the
mainstream now
how the media shames people out of an
honestly held or religiously held
opinion on controversial issues
and it's going to get worse unless
people speak up
if you followed political commentary at
all this entry you know megyn kelly
one of the most influential voices on
the political scene for well over a
decade
she's been at the forefront of political
news covering elections hosting debates
providing commentary since she began at
fox news in 2004.
at fox she hosted multiple hit shows
including the wildly popular america
live
as well as the unbelievably popular the
kelly file after leaving fox in 2017
she went on to host megyn kelly today on
nbc
a self-made media giant megan has been
one of the strongest voices for real
female empowerment
as opposed to the toxic brand of modern
feminism that's so often peddled in the
media
now having left behind traditional
television megan has moved into my
territory the world of podcasting
her new show the megan kelly show
premiered last month with her
hard-hitting commentary and an
incredible slate of staggeringly
illustrious guests such as well
me and probably some others the show has
been an instant success
as successful as megan has been in her
career she's also repeatedly found
herself embroiled in controversy
from her challenges at fox news to her
feud with donald trump to her tumultuous
relationship with nbc
megan and i discussed all of the facts
and explored what the media just got
plain wrong
there's more to the story than you might
think hope you enjoy our conversation
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special just a
reminder we'll be doing some bonus
questions at the end of the show with
megyn kelly the only way you can get
access to that part of the conversation
is to become a member
head on over to dailywire.com become a
member you'll have access to all of the
full conversations with every one of our
awesome guests
megan thanks so much for joining the
show hey thanks for having me ben good
to see you
so obviously we're recording this
slightly in advance of when it's going
to come out so the state of the race
could change
but let's talk obviously from the from
the outset about what you see the state
of the race
as with regard to president trump and
and joe biden
it seems like there have been all these
dramatic events but one thing stays
fairly consistent then that is the
polling data the polling data seems to
consistently suggest a large national
lead for joe biden
and a pretty solid state lead for biden
in most of the swing states
and even the states that shouldn't be
swing state seem pretty close
how do you gauge this election right now
well right now trump's losing
i i think that's true because it biden's
ahead in every poll
in virtually every state and has been
steadily but i almost view it as a
basketball game ben where you know i
don't really watch a lot of basketball
but doug puts it on and i keep an eye on
it and what i've realized
over the years is you only ever need to
tune in for the last two minutes of a
basketball game
there's no point in watching the whole
game all everything that determines
what's going to happen is the last two
minutes
and i think these margins are probably
going to tighten significantly before we
get to november 3rd
and people are still deciding whether
they're really going to vote for biden i
mean disaffected republicans
they may not like trump but it's a big
thing to vote for a guy who's going to
pack the supreme court with a bunch of
democrats and change you know basically
get rid of the head of the third branch
of government like
that's so i i do think people are still
wrestling with some of that
and that we'll see a tightening and if
it gets tighter you know as as tight as
we saw with trump and hillary
then he's back in business but the one
caveat to that is
don't forget what happened last time was
a couple days before the election
jim comey came out with there's new
hidden documents on the computer
uma abedin has them and anthony weiner
was back in the news because he was
harboring them and
that's how they found them blah blah
blah and that was a huge
game changer for trump i mean i i
remember being on the set with sean sean
hannity was coming on after the kelly
file was done
and he had been saying like i can't
quite get him to 270. i can get him 267
i can't go and get him from 270. he came
into the studio that night and he goes
he's back he's back so
you know we'll see if there's an october
surprise that really helps him like that
but right now
he he does he's got some ground to make
up for sure
well what's pretty amazing is that if
you look at some of the polling data on
the underlying issues
trump really in like a normal election
cycle should be walking away with this
thing there's a gallup poll that came
out this week
that showed 56 percent of americans say
they are better off now than they were
four years ago
which is normally the key question when
you are having a re-election race is are
you better off now than you were four
years ago
and there's a that same poll showed that
49 of americans said that they like
trump's policies as opposed to 46
percent of americans who like joe
biden's policies and yet he's getting
just absolutely swamped
in the in the national polling data and
it does lend support to the idea that
many of us have been saying on the
conservative side of the aisle for a
long time which is that
the trump administration in terms of
performance has been quite good
if we could just somehow you know pair
away all of the affect which is what a
lot of the fans seem to like
then this would not be a close race and
he would actually be winning at this
point
yeah i know but you know what there's no
question trump does a lot of
self-inflicted wounds you know like
tweeting or calling calling kamala
harris a monster that's not smart that's
not smart politics who are you going to
reach what woman sitting at home in
suburban philadelphia is going to be
like
yeah now i'm voting for him um so you
know the goal is to widen the tent at
this point widen
and there's no more necessary appeals to
his base they're with him so like just a
little bit wider and like just a little
bit of self-restraint
i don't have any problem with all like
the helicopter ride to the hospital
after or to the white house after kobe
that that's just trump being his
dramatic self
but i will say especially having watched
this race as more of a consumer
over the past two years as opposed to an
anchor
he is fighting the media he does have a
third enemy in this
and he recognized it early on and he
knew he had to demonize the media make
them quote the enemy
um but they actually are his enemy and
you know you know that the press
coverage of him has been 90 negative
and continues to be they're completely
unfair to him and there are still very
fair-minded people out there
consuming the news not understanding
that
still trusting what they're hearing on
cnn
and i i think it's been a huge problem
for trump if he loses
i think the media will have had a lot to
do with it so let's talk about that so
i want to kind of re frame and and talk
about your career in the media because
you've really been able to experience
the media from all sides i mean
you went from being uh sort of a local
reporter all the way up to the biggest
anchor on
fox news and then you moved over to the
so-called mainstream media and you
worked in those halls so i want to talk
about
how the media runs from all these
different perspectives we'll talk about
that in just
one second but first we need to talk
about life insurance
it is halloween this month and policy
genius would love to mark the occasion
by making something less scary
life insurance now shopping for life
insurance can seem like a daunting task
policy genius makes it easy
they combine a cutting edge insurance
marketplace with help from licensed
experts to save you time and money
right now you could save 50 or more by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a decade those
savings really start to add up so here's
how it works first
you head over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find your best price policy
genius will compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day you might even be eligible to skip
that in-person medical exam which is
super convenient once you apply policy
genius handles all the paperwork and the
red tape the best part they work for you
not the insurance company so if you get
any speed bumps during the application
process they'll take care of everything
for you there's a reason policy genius
has a five-star rating across over 1600
reviews on trustpilot and google so
if you need life insurance head on over
to policygenius.com
right now to get started remember you
could say 50 or more by comparing quotes
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and super important to get it
right
let's talk about your media career
because a lot of people don't actually
know your background they just know that
you're really famous and that you're
really popular but they don't know kind
of
your early beginnings so how did you get
to be you know
megan kelly who's on fox news which is
where most people i think on the
conservative side of the aisle first saw
you
well i used to be a lawyer i mean i'm
still a lawyer but i used to be a
practicing attorney
and i did that for about nine and a half
years
and then was miserable and just realized
i know you know the experience
i lasted a little longer than you did in
the game but you know i really loved it
i
i like you had a humble background and
for me becoming megyn kelly esquire
it was such an ego boost i was so proud
of myself i thought
people are going to have to take me
seriously now you know i didn't go to
harvard
i went to albany but still i'm just
saying like as a young woman coming up
nobody in my family was a doctor or a
lawyer or anything like this it was like
okay this is something
so i held on to it a lot longer uh
because it meant something to me to
me as a human but over and over and over
there's only so many years you can spend
that unhappy
in doing what you're doing and it wasn't
because of my law firm or my colleagues
it was just the job itself
is it's pretty soul crushing and and the
grind of it was
i just i couldn't anymore so
what happened was i actually went to
visit a friend of mine in boston who has
zero dough she's a nurse and she was
living not very well off you know and we
had such a good time
and i was just reminded of my own roots
like i don't need all this money
i i am totally happy with my friend in
the bar
getting 50 cent beers like i'm good this
is kind of what i need and nothing much
more
and i came back to chicago and after a
series of events i just decided i was
going to try to do
something else one thing led to another
a woman in my guitar class
worked at the wmaq which is the chicago
ono
for nbc she offered to help me make a
resume tape i did it
i cold called a bunch of news directors
i wound up walking the tape in
to the office of bill lord down in
washington because my husband and i my
first husband had had moved to baltimore
at that point
and that poor sucker put me on tv and i
did it part time while practicing law
for about a year and then
i gave my tape to kim hume at fox and
they hired me in the dc bureau
and so what was it like working as a as
a
reporter as opposed to working as sort
of the anchor uh because
again you've worked in a bunch of these
different roles i loved it
honestly like that was some of my most
fun times in
journalism it was great because when i
first got hired i thought i was going to
be more of a legal correspondent and
maybe
commentator and i
was getting ready to go and i was going
to work just fridays just to begin
i was still practicing law and uh i said
to bill lord
because the first day was uh day when
hurricane isabel or
i can't res isabel was coming through
and i was like oh you don't need me
right like
that has nothing to do with my skills
and he was like if you don't have a
raincoat a rain slicker and rain boots
you better get them and get in here
i'm like oh god so i go in that night
they didn't put me on the air that night
but i i went and i sat in the control
room
it was the first time i'd ever been in a
control room which was so chaotic
on a breaking news night like that you
got reporters all over and they're
getting blown around by their
hurricane-like winds
and i will never forget um
i'll i'll clean it up for your audience
but there was this one guy
they were trying to get him on his name
was eric hong he's a reporter
and they couldn't get him on they're
coming to you coming to you and then
somebody other feed came in
and they couldn't get them on and the ep
yelled at him you're not getting on
wjla after you they i have to i'm like
oh
my god it's like a crazy environment in
here
and that really was an appropriate
introduction to news which is
it's it's ugly behind the scenes and
it's not high brow
in any way and uh it was a good
introduction because i'll tell you this
man
when i first started fox i was
frustrated because
there's no achieving perfection in the
news it's just you can't you don't have
enough time you don't have enough staff
and it's not the way news works
but in the law you can come near
perfection in your brief
in your argument in your presentation
everyone looks good all the time and i i
was frustrated
and i remember talking to kim hume and i
was like you know it's
it's hard because i am used to sort of
the american airlines
first class cloth napkin real silverware
service to my audience to my clients
and she goes yeah we're southwest
airlines
and she was right it was just you got to
get you got to get a little grittier
if you're going to go into news and
especially cable news and as it turns
out
that wound up suiting me just fine so
when you started off you were doing
the the sort of objective news stuff and
then obviously you moved into kelly file
in which case your perspective was
allowed to come out a little bit more so
what was the difference between doing
those two things because we see now this
complete merger of the two
i obviously look at cnn where they
promote chris cuomo as an objective news
anchor or don lemon as an objective
news anchor but you made a pretty stark
division in your own career from
objective news reporter to
megyn kelly of the kelly file where your
perspective was incredibly clear and you
were pretty open about
it what was the difference between those
two roles
well i mean i think that you can you can
maintain your journalistic cred
um by being open and honest about what
you're opining on and when it's opinion
and what you won't opine on you know i
don't understand being calling yourself
a credible news anchor
and going out there and openly ripping
on president trump and everything he
does every night and calling him a bad
man an evil and a racist
like that's not reporting that's a
that's pure opinion
and i feel like you go there and you you
can no longer call yourself a straight
news reporter
however i was never hesitant to call
somebody who is you know driving
200 miles an hour down the highway while
a woman's pushing her baby in a baby
stroller an idiot
and i think that sort of is what
distinguished me from
some other people on the air i would
take more editorial risks
like that on what i considered common
sense issues
that weren't incredibly divisive and
what my my main commitment was
was to the facts and when people veered
offline when it came to the facts
i always hit them in the head it was
like get back stay right stay
in the right lane and that's how this
discussion is going to go and so
i think i mean i'm seeing it now with
the black lives matter narrative like
if you just stick with the facts like
what are the numbers when it comes to
police shootings what
what are the racial divisions what is
the what are the crime statistics
people freak out but they just want you
to say what they want you to say
but as you know facts don't care about
your feelings is somebody really smart
always says and um i'm in that lane like
i
i don't care if you don't like it these
are the facts and we can't have a
reasonable argument unless we stick to
that
so i think it sort of stuck out a bit as
like she's different and she you know
she's saying she's defending the police
it's like well
if the facts are defensive of them then
yes i guess so i'm defending the facts
anyway that's sort of how it went and i
always tried to hold on to my
objectivity like
even when trump was coming up and he was
very controversial a lot of republicans
didn't like him
i was never out there night after night
being like he's terrible how could the
republicans do this
i would just report on him fairly then i
defended him on a lot of the
bs being thrown at him and then when he
did something really
you know crazy like saying judge curiel
couldn't decide his trump university
case because he was of hispanic
heritage i hit him you know like as a
lawyer i always felt comfortable giving
my opinion
so anyway it's it's a bit of a hybrid
approach but i would
submit it is it looks nothing like what
we're seeing
now in the media with people like don
lemon
who's just a joke and chris cuomo who's
much more worried about his muscles than
he is about the facts
i just can't watch cnn anymore and i'm
angry about it because i used to like
cnn but
those days are gone so let's talk about
your career at fox news
obviously you've been involved in pretty
much every high profile fox news story
uh for the last what ten years uh and uh
and that really
began with uh i mean now in retrospect
uh roger ailes who obviously
was a genius at what he did at fox news
but also happened to be
it turns out like a really terrible
person so what exactly
uh was your relationship with roger
ailes and
and what was your perspective on how he
ran fox news you know can i start with
this on
i want to start with this because was
roger a terrible person
he was a flawed man he was a deeply
flawed man
he was also in some ways a great man
and i remember talking a friend of mine
who's in pr she's a democrat but i
remember saying
you know what should i say when people
ask me whether he was awful or
raised that because i i have really
mixed feelings about it and she said you
just say he was terrible
that's it just say it was terrible and i
the truth is i it's more nuanced than
that you know
i can't speak to all these guys who've
gone down it's i think it's really hard
to
see how harvey weinstein could be a
great guy um
but in roger's case i spent enough time
with him
that i know how magnanimous he was how
what good care he took of so many
employees
what a strong leader he was how clever
he was what a patriot he was
how much he loved the armed forces and
did so much for them
i just it's hard to completely write him
off as awful because
of this other side even though the other
side is indefensible
um so anyway just to start with that
when when he first hired me
it was we got along well i knew right
from the start he was sort of body
and frankly so am i so i i didn't judge
that i
as you know i don't speak the queen's
english and i'm totally fine with 12
year old boy humor
and uh i just it's tough to offend me so
we we got along great and i kind of like
that about him
as i would later find out is much better
than the alternative of like
you know the the broadcast world of like
everyone but us
is awful and um
then he started sort of taking me up
into his office and the conversations
veered because it'd be like two hour
sessions where you go in there and talk
to him
and and he would always lock the door
which is you know
you don't want your boss to lock your
door uh when you go in there
and um it's just sort of more from like
body talk to directly sexual
talk directed at you and as a woman
you're sitting there like
oh god like i don't want this like
i can see what he's doing and you're
like i don't want this because i'm
making it i'm
making my bones here like i am reporting
well i'm breaking news
it was right there in the duke lacrosse
scandal that i was covering for fox and
i was
breaking a lot of stories on that and
you can that what what you're thinking
in your head is
i'm gonna have to reject him at some
point and then my career is derailed
like it's over no man wants to be
rejected
by a woman and no man that is rejected
by a woman then has good feelings about
her after the fact
these are facts of human nature and so
when you suddenly realize the
relationship is morphed for him
into a different lane and you're slower
in this lane you're scared
you know you you know what's coming and
really all you want to do is like shrink
down to your smallest self and hope he
stops noticing you
which is directly the opposite of what
you're hoping in the professional lane
right you want him to notice you
so it's very complicated and i for the
longest time just pretended i wasn't
hearing what i was hearing i just laugh
it off
and then it got to the point where i
could no longer pretend
because he grabbed me and tried to make
out with me three times in his office
and i basically ran out the door
so that's tough to ignore long story
short ben
after that i just ignored him i did
report this to a supervisor at fox news
who gave me the advice of just ignore
him he's going through a rough time in
his marriage he'll be fine
and i was happy to have that that advice
you know like okay he took a shot that
men do that um and that was kind of the
end of it
and then when the whole gretchen carlson
thing came up and i have there's no love
lost between me and gretchen i'm not a
fan of hers and i don't think she's a
fan of mine um
but the question was being put to people
directly
is he capable of this and everyone is
rushing to the camera saying he's not
capable of no way it's not possible not
this man and i was like
i don't know about that i feel
uncomfortable and then
i was told by somebody close to roger on
his team that they had managed to limit
the investigation into him
to just his immediate small circle of
people and that or her
her immediate gretchen's immediate small
circle of people in her show
which would not include any talent which
wouldn't include sort of any of the more
prominent females at the company
and that was when i knew i i had to come
forward like i i didn't know what he was
but i knew they had to take a real look
at it like so they needed a real
investigation
and that's that's what they wound up
doing so he fell
he died not long after that and i cried
when he died and
i talked to janice dean who was in the
whole thing with me we were
shoulder-to-shoulder on all of it she
had a story with him
and to this day i feel sad about i feel
sad about what's going on at fox because
i think it's
a lot different than it used to be when
he was at the helm
and so i think we really lost something
we lost something when he died and when
he left fox but
it was because of roger you know that's
what people lose sight of who get mad at
me or get mad at the women
who come forward he he cost himself
and the rest of us his leadership so
anyway it's still a sad subject for me
and um you know one that's just not it's
not black and white
well it does go to media bias in a
different way which is of course that
hollywood then goes ahead and makes an
entire movie based on this
uh in which you're portrayed by
charlie's thrawn and they never even
bother to call you up and ask
for any of your input on the script so
they're telling largely your story
uh without ever having asked you a
single question i i want to get your
thoughts on that
well they clearly stole my book i mean i
when i saw the movie i was like oh
somebody's been reading my it's settle
for more it's still available online
um and so i was like well that's
interesting like
nobody offered me a check for that which
i wouldn't have taken
actually i did get a purchase offer for
the book and i said no but it wasn't
from them
um so i don't know it i also had mixed
feelings about the movie which
yeah i had no involvement with but i
thought okay it's good to shine a light
on sexual harassment because there's
still a lot of young women out there who
have no clue how to deal with it when it
happens to them and i
i like that piece of it it's like here's
a here's what happened here take from
what you will but i knew they were going
to portray fox news as you know just
some
parody of itself and that they were
going to rip on people i loved in ways
that were unfair and indeed they did
brian kilmeade in particular took it on
the chin in a way that was really unfair
really unfair um they don't care right
they just and they made roger they tried
to get to some of his humanity but they
really made him look like a monster
um and i watched it ben and it was
really just
it was painful for me for so many
reasons the ones i've outlined and also
because
i lost a lot of friends at fox as a
result of that you know there were roger
loyalists in the building
who just couldn't forgive me and uh
it still makes me upset to this day they
just don't understand um
so you know you move on but the media of
course has they loved to take down roger
ailes and they played up that story way
more
than some of the other stories of
democrats falling and
there's no accident you know there's no
there's a reason that there was there
were all these films about roger ailes
right like there was the showtime one
and then there was the bombshell one
there was some other
third one meanwhile i've seen like one
little film about harvey that
got no numbers that was like quietly
released like okay he was a serial
rapist
so can you tell me which one is bigger
and then meanwhile
uh they somehow continue to portray you
as the villainous
no matter what the situation is so let's
talk about sort of
uh what happened on fox news that
prompted your move to nbc so
you're on fox news you've got these
enormous ratings i remember because you
were kind enough to have me on your show
at the time
you always rated it for me oh thank you
i appreciate it well
i mean it was your show uh and uh and
then the 2016 election cycle comes about
and the whole trumpian split happens in
which
everybody is divvied up into you're
either pro-trump or you're anti-trump
there is no middle
and uh in which trump uh took uh
personal offense to you asking him
difficult questions specifically about
his treatment
of women i want to ask about that in
just one second but first let's talk
about
something really important you can do
for yourself or your family i'm talking
about preserving those family memories i
mean out
in the garage right now you got old film
reels you got vhs tapes you even have a
vcr anymore
of course you don't you have a bunch of
old pictures none of them are digitized
but you need them in digital format so
that you can
move around with them so you can view
them on your computer so you can print
new copies
well how can you accomplish this massive
task taking all of these old
these old materials and transferring
them over to digital the process from
start finish is easy with legacy box
you pack and you send legacy box
digitizes everything by hand and then
you enjoy
you get back perfectly preserved digital
copies on thumb drive dvd or the cloud
now ready to watch and share and enjoy
they've thought of everything they even
provide state-of-the-art tracking they
send you updates at every step of the
process
send your precious recorded moments to a
company you can trust legacy box was
founded by college roommates nick and
adam over a decade ago i know them they
are great dudes today
legacy box is the world's largest
digitizers of home movies and photos
over 850 000 families have trusted them
to digitally preserve their past
they've got a team of over 200 trained
technicians everything is digitized by
hand at their 50 000
square foot processing campus in
chattanooga tennessee we discover those
glory days by digitizing all of your
irreplaceable heirlooms with legacy box
go to legacybox.com shapiro get an
incredible 40 off your first order buy
today
take advantage of this exclusive offer
then send in the legacy box when you're
ready go to legacy box dot com
shapiro save 40 while supplies last okay
so
let's talk about the uh the trump
election cycle so
uh you are tapped to moderate uh some of
the republican debates and you of course
ask trump some pretty tough questions
about his treatment of women in the past
to which he says that he only did it to
rosie o'donnell and such
and then he gets very angry at you and
you are one of the first into the dunk
tank when it comes to if donald trump is
angry at you
then all of his supporters are also
angry at you uh and this turns into a
very polarized environment for you at
fox
and i won't if you talk about that a
little bit well that was a hard time
and in the moment i wasn't sure if he
was really angry or if he was just using
me as
just another storyline which trump likes
to create and now i think he was
genuinely angry in response to that
question and i don't
actually even think it had so much to do
with the question itself as he felt
betrayed by me
he thought that i was at fox i liked him
which i did like him
but you know i like them all i like ben
carson too but i basically accused him
of being an idiot in my question to him
that night but he didn't complain
right the way the way trump did um you
know
it's not beanbag it's a political debate
for the presidency like you're gonna
give him your fastball
and you know for the record trump
handled it very well like his answer was
just fine like hey
say what i say people are sick of this
pc nonsense and we have fun you don't
like it too bad
great that's vintage trump
uh so if he hadn't chosen to make a
thing out of it it wouldn't have become
a thing
but it was very hard because you could
feel the fracturing of the audience it
was sort of at that point
the more sort of trumpian wing which at
that point was more of the breitbart
wing
and then the more national review type
republicans who were like more
old-school republicans who didn't
they were more mitt romney types or
really just sort of mainstream it didn't
have to be a
mitt romney thing and roger was really
desperate to keep those two factions
together as our audience
and did not want this war which is
already happening it wasn't just because
of me it was already happening in the
republican party i just
i was a piece of it because of trump and
um
i i felt like people were
misunderstanding i wanted people to go
back and just look at the debate
in in whole and see the questions that
we asked of all of them right they were
all really hard and they were
great and the republicans did great that
night they it was like the highest rated
debate ever
right at that point um
anyway there was no standing him down so
i just decided to ignore it and ignore
it
as much as i could but it just blew up
my life you know it was like
it wasn't like mean tweets which are
like oh that's not nice it was
security threats like people showing up
at my house in the middle of the night
and scary stuff you know like getting in
my face when i'm on the street with my
kids
um you know like when some strange man
comes and approaches you and yells at
you on the streets of new york in a
threatening manner you're with your
children
you like as a woman especially you're
kind of like i don't know
where is this going and what am i going
to do if this escalates and you never
want to give anybody
um a videotape right you don't have a
fight you certainly don't have a
physical fight but there's just a lot of
that
and i i didn't understand it was like it
was a tough question
um so anyway i think
trump saw me and that storyline as a way
of telegraphing to his base
that there was no one he wouldn't stand
up to um establishment
media fox anchor like fox he wasn't
beholden to fox roger rails not beholden
to him
and i think that's why trump's poll
numbers went up after that whole thing
it wasn't
like a verdict necessarily on me or fox
or the question it was a verdict on i
like this guy
who doesn't give a damn about what
people say about him
he's going to buck convention he's going
to wreck everything
and i that's what we need we need the
guy in that package to go to washington
and wreck a system that isn't working
for us
and that's where it landed i will say
for the record as mean as things got
online and you know people write
terrible things about me
and so on my ratings never went down in
fact they only went up
they never suffered yeah i mean i think
that that is one of the
great lies there they're two great lies
i think about the the take on trump
particularly in the right-wing media
during 2016. one was that
uh if you went anti-trump you did so
specifically for the ratings which was
crazy uh and the other lie was that if
you
was that if you went to anti-trump you'd
lose your entire base and these these
two lies were being maintained at the
exact same time one was that you were
doing it for the ratings and the other
was it would kill your ratings
if you're critical of trump and it turns
out that people can hold more than one
thought in their head
at the exact same time moving on from
kind of where you word fox is so you
decide that you're you're basically
ready to
move on what were the factors that went
into the decision making because at the
time you were the highest rated
show on fox news you were the biggest
anchor on on the right
and now you've decided to move on and go
not only to network news you want to run
nbc
but also to to do something completely
different right do something much softer
sort of a return to
uh your journalistic roots a little bit
uh what prompted that decision
well i mean not unlike when i left the
law i was
i went headfirst in the brick wall of
unhappiness and i know people
loved the kelly file and i actually
loved the kelly file too i miss it i
wish i could
i wish i could watch a show like that
now as a news consumer
um but i wasn't happy at
all in my personal life i you know the
life of a cable news anchor especially
primetime
news anchor is not pleasant it's not
good i don't know a lot of really joyful
cable news primetime hosts it's it's
it's like working in the coliseum for a
living
every day is another fight another
attack another person calling you
something awful and then having to have
big meetings about it what are we going
to do and you know this isn't who you
are and you know your base
understands your base audience
understands it's not you but you got to
fight some war and then your kids are
seeing this stuff and it's like oh my
god
so you got to get a thick skin but you
also do have to devote a lot of time to
controversy
and then you know now it's to the point
where you're getting attacked by all the
other news anchors too
and then after the roger thing i was you
know getting attacked by some people
internally
uh so it was fighting fighting fighting
non-stop
and in the meantime you look at my home
life
and like you i have a very tight family
i have i wind up getting a divorce
my first husband back in 2006 and i met
and married doug
my husband now we have a great marriage
and we've worked really hard for it and
i i'm proud of it and we have three
great kids and i wasn't seeing
any of them i mean i basically wasn't
mothering my own children
and i don't you can say it's sexist i
don't care what anybody says it it
wasn't i wasn't happy i wanted to mother
my own kids
and i know this is sexist to say that i
think women have a
have a special desire to be with their
children maybe more so than a lot of men
um that's that happens to be my belief
and for me
it was insurmountable i was not able to
be sort of the wall street dad who went
to work at 6am and came home at 11 pm
and never saw his children during the
day i i couldn't do it my kids were
little ben when i left the kelly file
they were three five and seven they were
babes you know and i
i i could still be there i hadn't missed
the whole thing
so it's like on the one hand my
professional life is really unhappy and
i'm not enjoying it
on the other hand my home life which i
really want to be at
is not available to me you know it's not
it's not there so
i ask myself like what do i want to do
what do i want to do
and fox offered me a bunch of money to
stay and i just thought there's no
there's
not enough enough money that i don't
want to live like this
i don't care i could i could go back and
have the 50 cent beers like my nurse
friend in boston
i don't care now i didn't have to do
that because nbc made me a nice offer
but
the reason i chose them and this is
where i went wrong
was they were like you can do a morning
show you can be home by noon
to be with your kids and we'll still use
you on the big nights like election
nights and so on so i can still sort of
do my politics coverage when i wanted
i'm like all right that's a decent
compromise so i was looking at the
landscape even back then i'm like i'm
not going to go to cnn i'm definitely
not going to msnbc right so those are
those two are out
so it kind of leaves the three main
networks for something more reasonable
and there's really not going on a lot
going on at cbs abc did offer me a role
but i didn't find it that attractive and
then there was nbc that said here's this
thing you can do something that may be
more uplifting to the world
and then go home be with your kids so
i'm like okay i'm going to try it i'll
try something new
i'll exercise a new muscle and
it was the most stressful year and a
half of my life
and um you know i was i'll tell you this
a lot of my fans have been like
hated the ending you know it wasn't fair
but i will say death uh let's say ben
that when you're dying
death by a thousand cuts sometimes the
big machete
is a mercy you know that's how it was
for me
yeah i mean from the outside and as
somebody with whom
i consider his friends uh you know
watching how nbc
news set you up to fail i mean they set
you up from the very outset almost i
mean they're the very first show that
you did
you did this pretty hard-hitting
interview with alex jones and it was
clear
from all of the promotional materials
that you were not going to be
soft-peddling alex jones
and then the entire media decided that
in fact you'd become a propagandist on
behalf of alex jones yeah
in the media and this is like the very
first episode right and alex jones is a
pretty important figure at the time
because trump had been talking with him
and had been doing his show
and all of this sort of stuff and the
media set it up as here's megyn kelly
who's now promoting
a cons crazed conspiracy theorist and
nbc didn't really defend you in any way
they just sort of left you out there to
hang
and to me from the outside look like
okay here's an early indicator of how
this thing is going to go
all the conservative preconceived
notions about
what exactly it's like in the world of
mainstream media are correct
the alex jones things was was nuts
because it was like suddenly a new rule
was imposed where we
only get to interview the good guys
that's it no journalist can interview i
mean while i'm like
diane sawyer interviewed jeffrey dahmer
and there wasn't this guy like as far as
i know alex jones
hasn't eaten anybody okay so spare me
like cnn did an in-depth invest uh
interview with alex jones
right after the new town massacre it was
right after he was saying all this crazy
stuff
they didn't even touch on most of it
they gave him a total pass
the new york times interviewed alex
jones i could go on
nothing no one said boo but megyn kelly
wants to do it and it's like
the national enquirer had a cover
um with me on it at the time that with a
caption
most hated mom in america oh my god
and my neighbor down at we have a house
at the jersey shore or my neighbor she
ran in there her name was kitty
and she took all the magazines down and
she was like how dare you she shops in
here with her children
she was getting all the magazines and
you know throwing in her car
so it was otherworldly because i was
like
you know i mean you could go down the
list charles manson all these
murderers who have been interviewed on
television but somehow
alex jones was a bridge too far and i
100 stand by that
interview they pointed to the fact that
some of the newtown families didn't want
it to happen and that i understand
but the truth of that is six of the
newtown families
objected and 19 were either very pro
or at a minimum neutral so that didn't
get covered you know but you can't
you can't do news coverage that way
based on on who
might get upset you have to do the news
and he was in the news and trump was
circulating publicly
alex jones's information and stuff from
infowars and it was high time somebody
took a hard look at him
and i think it was pretty quickly after
that trump actually stopped trafficking
as much with infowars so
obviously it had it had some impact so
what was the relationship like with the
nbc executives because
it really did feel like they were
hanging you out to dry like they put you
out there and then
within five minutes of putting you out
there it felt like they just completely
disappeared like normally a network
defends its own
anchors normally a network will actually
protect its own
anchors and you see this with anchors
who are who say incredibly controversial
things i mean fox news routinely
will defend tucker if tucker says
something that's controversial
you see cnn continues to defend its
anchors but nbc really just sort of
felt like they cut you off at the knees
looking at it from the outside
well let me put it to you this way there
are very few network
executives as steely spined as lachlan
murdoch
roger ailes suzanne scott and jay
wallace very few
precious view and um you know i talked
about roger earlier you know when i was
at fox he would 100 have your back
if any controversy came your way the
first thing he would do is go run in
front of the bullet and take it for you
and if i may put it this way
not every network executive is as brave
or as strong
or as smart as that and um that's all
i'm going to say
so looking at sort of your tenure on the
mornings uh in in nbc the long nights
were out very early in terms of
everybody looking at the ratings and
saying the ratings were not good and of
course they were saying that from like
the the very beginning when normally
when you transition from one anchor to
another there of course is a sort of
lead time before you can start to build
ratings so how much of what happened at
nbc do you think was about the ratings
and and how much do you think it was
about politics well
um i mean we were we were building in
their ratings our numbers were going up
and our advertising revenue was going
way up like we were making more money on
that show than the show had been making
prior so the advertisers loved it
um and we did we needed some time and i
talked to hoda and
kathy lee about their show and it was a
bomb in the ratings the first couple of
years a bomb
but they let them stay on and they
didn't start actually doing positive
readings until five years into the gig
so especially morning television it
takes some time
and we were on a good trajectory but of
course we hadn't gotten it done in the
short time that i was on the air there
i do think you know i'll say this i was
out there defending brett kavanaugh a
lot
on nbc i was and remain horrified by
what happened to him
i thought it was grossly unfair i i gave
christine blasey ford a fair hearing
both on the air and in my own mind i i
listened to her
i thought it was worthwhile hearing what
she had to say
i had no problem with like sizing her up
everybody who came after that was a joke
everybody and and
like not only we all go to julie
swetnick the one who made the ridiculous
gang rape stuff
through michael avenatti which is a
farce but when i was at nbc
people forget this one they went to air
with a report that brett kavanaugh's old
girlfriend
that that the girlfriend's mother
remembered her daughter
telling her that brett kavanaugh had
shoved her into a brick wall
uh back when they were dating several
years ago and they
they put it was all anonymously sourced
they were just saying somebody has told
us this is the mother's
saying this they put that on the air now
keep in mind this is a network that
would not put on the harvey weinstein
allegations even though they had rose
mcgowan and other women
on the record saying he was a predator
right rose mcgowan was on the record
saying he raped me
we don't have our facts yet we can't go
with it now you got like anonymous
person saying the mother
of somebody said should the boardman
once said it's like a triple here
hearsay
they put on the air somebody else winds
up tracking down the actual girlfriend
who is like
100 untrue none of that ever happened
he's an amazing guy
that's the kind of reporting that was
going on about brett and i was there
trying to be my lawyerly self and look
at the facts
and i'll just say this it was like the
old sesame street song like
one of these things is not like the
others and uh i think i felt that
while i was there so in a second i want
to ask you about the controversy of
course that
that was really the excuse for them to
get rid of you it was pretty obvious
what was going on right there i'm going
to ask you about that in just one second
first let's talk about protecting your
online data
now when you use the bathroom you always
close the door behind you right
you don't want randos looking at you
that'd be weird and strange so why would
you let people look in
at your internet activity using the
internet without expressvpn it's like
going to the bathroom and not closing
the door
did you know your isp comcast verizon
att
they know every single website you visit
and what's worse they can sell this
information to ad companies and tech
giants who will use your data to target
you
expressvpn puts a stop to all of this it
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
your online activity can't be seen by
anybody
i use expressvpn on all my devices it
works on everything phones laptops even
routers
so if somebody's sharing your wi-fi they
can be protected even if they don't
personally have expressive vpn
the best part is using expressvpn it's
as easy as closing the bathroom door
just fire up the app click one button
now you're protected expressvpn it's the
world's number one rated vpn by cnetwire
the verge and countless others so
if you're like me and you believe that
your online activity is your business
secure yourself today by visiting
expressvpn.com
ben use my exclusive link s s vpn
e-x-p-r
com slash ben you can get extra three
months for free that's expressvpn.com
ben so obviously all of this culminates
in one of the great
faux controversies of all time in which
you're talking about
the latest blackface controversy in
which somebody is caught years ago
wearing blackface i can't remember what
the context was i'm sure you will um but
you make the absolutely inarguable claim
that it is different to dress up as
michael jackson for halloween than it is
to dress up
in 1920s style blackface in order to
mock black people
and this results in nbc news basically
using it as an excuse to get rid of you
now this is so non-controversial that
i've point blank asked basically every
democrat i can find about this
ranging from juan williams to to members
of the general public
and they're all like yeah i mean that is
perfectly obviously true because anyone
who has a sentient
capacity anyone has a prefrontal cortex
understands there's a difference between
i dressed up
as a person of color whom i admire and
i'm dressing up as a person of color to
mock people of color
there's a difference between ralph
northam dressing up as michael jackson
and between ralph northam and dressing
up as a stereotypical black person and
or a kkk member so that like
these are very obviously different you
make this perfectly obvious point a
point
also made by joy behar who i notice
still works for network news
and uh and you were basically tossed out
the window for it
while they proclaimed that you were
racist i mean
what was all of that well i mean you you
have it basically right i was i was on
the
what happened in terms of my
presentation i what happened was a real
housewife
luanne de lesseps was in the news for
she dressed like diana ross
and she she tinted her skin she actually
just put on extra self-tanner
um so she did look darker than she
normally does and she had you know
she looked like diana ross with the wig
and the dress and they were killing her
keep in mind by the way this is this is
a show produced by bravo which is owned
by nbc
um universal and and it was pre-taped
and they put it on the air they put her
on the air
with the you know the tinted skin so
that that was their decision
she got a lot of blow back and i wanted
to talk about it because we were talking
about all the crackdowns on halloween
costumes
we started that day with a discussion
about how over in the uk
they sent out at some university a ban
on
like any costume that would that would
look like a cowboy
because they didn't want you to offend
american cowboys
in response to which every american
cowboy was like stfu
like we don't need your help please um
right and when they actually suggested
to
to people that you know you might
consider dressing as something
non-controversial
perhaps as a letter or a number
that's where we've gotten on halloween
and i was talking about how like the
standards for what's offensive
change and not everybody understands
when they're when they're walking into
something that they know suddenly
they're doing something that's awful and
i pointed to lou ann de la sept i'm like
this woman
she wore this she's trying to honor
diana ross and
you know everything got blown up and i
said 30 years ago when i was a kid the
point i was trying to make was
you do that and like there wasn't a lot
of blow back and
uh suddenly that became controversial
and then i said
you know when you look when i look at
her i look i see a woman who's trying to
look
just like diana ross she loves diana
ross and she's trying to honor her
so i didn't even really say this is fine
i said this is what i see
tell me if i'm wrong that's it that is
all that happened that day
and then when i looked i looked in the
newspaper headlines it was basically
like megyn kelly calls for a return to
minstrel show blackface
and you know did the show in a kkk hat
it was like
oh but honestly by that point
i was used to being misrepresented by
the press you know it's like everything
they had said about me over the past
year was untrue
and i had tried to just take the high
road and not respond
and that was also what i felt i needed
to do
in that latest incident i went back on
the air the next day
after being told by everybody there that
i was hideous and that i had said
something terrible
and did what i think is right which is
when you think you've genuinely offended
a bunch of people
you should say you're sorry and um so i
did
and then i had a panel on to talk about
blackface the history of blackface and
sort of get to the question i was asking
which is how do we go from a to b
right and like why is it people are
associating skin tinting in a modern day
costume meant to honor
with this really controversial practice
years ago
and i had a couple of black guests who
explained that and their their opinion
on it and they may
may or may not have persuaded people but
it was an interesting discussion
and and then i was never back on the air
again after that show
so i think for me it was frustrating not
to really be able to talk about it
i didn't i didn't know i didn't think it
would do me any good to come out and try
to defend myself by saying
at that point i did know that nbc had
put several shows on the air with people
wearing blackface like i knew jimmy
fallon had done it
and a couple of other people there had
done it and of course there had been
anchors wearing white face like lester
holt who when it
was bruce jenner um and also as uh the
woman from
uh what was it like american idol one of
those shows a susan boyle he wanted
susan boyle
but i was like i don't want to start
like firing at other anchors or other
personnel like this
that's not the answer here and what i
concluded was
the people who are offended you know by
this or have chosen to believe i'm a
racist because of remarks that have been
totally misrepresented or even if they
think my actual remarks were
racist they're not persuadable these are
these are not people who are open-minded
to me
so what's the point of just screaming
into the void and the people who don't
see any big deal of it don't
don't need to be convinced they know who
i am you know my actual audience both at
nbc and at fox they know who i am they
they understood
like this is something that was being
used it was being used
against me by people who couldn't stand
me you know the
the left who decided to generate this
huge campaign
which you know might have otherwise just
been a twitter campaign had it not had
buy-in
elsewhere in certain circles of power
um but when all was said and done ben i
was okay
because i walked away i did fine and
i was free you know i was free
and i i've never been through an
experience like i i was
i went through there and i i mean the
whole year not just that end
and i was relieved to just be out to be
back at my home which is safe with my
husband and my kids
and just take a breath to to try to
regroup because it was just such a
shocking
jarring upsetting turn of events in my
life
and i did it take a while to sort of
heal from that to be honest with you i'm
not going to try to pretend i'm made of
steel it was
it was hard i'd shed a lot of tears but
i got through it and i think like
anything you go through these things and
hopefully if you're
smart you don't get bitter and you get
better you get smarter
and i think maybe one of the reasons i
went through that or at least to take
away from it is
i get the whole cancel culture thing in
a way i otherwise wouldn't have i was
never in favor of it
but i worry because
obviously i'm financially secure i'm
fine financially and um
i'm i'm a public figure so i landed on
my feet and i have my own company now so
that's good
but what happens when this happens to a
civilian you know somebody who doesn't
have that kind of financial security
doesn't have that kind of platform
of national name built up already i feel
like i need to help them
i feel a responsibility to call
bs on what's happening to people in our
country right now i
i'm worried about our country i'm
worried about the kids who get this the
teenagers who get maligned as awful
bigots racists xenophobes
transphobes just for having an opinion
that may not go with the
you know the mainstream now how the
media shames people out of an honestly
held or religiously held opinion on
controversial issues
and it's gonna get worse unless people
speak
up so we have to find a way we have to
find a way of allowing that to happen
without people getting fired all the
time and
i don't know exactly what the answer is
i know that like douglas murray he says
you know when your company comes to you
and says you've got to take critical
race theory training you have to look at
them and say i refuse to allow you to
re-racialize
me my company or my country i refuse
it takes a lot of guts that's tough but
we got it figured out and so
that's one of the reasons why i came
back and i'm doing my podcast and i
i have my say you know i have a platform
where i can make these points
yeah i i will say that it is a in a
certain sort of perverse
short and frightened way it's it's
entertaining to watch the left eat its
own on some of this stuff
my favorite story around that actually
surrounds
that incident with you in which a
washington post employee dressed up as
you to try and mock you as racist
and then they were maligned by the other
people at the party as racist
and there was like a full washington
post investigation with heroic pictures
of the people complained about it it was
like these big beautiful photos
it's like wow okay you want to take this
to it's logical extreme i guess we're i
guess we're going to get there
uh you know it well to me that's so
funny because it's like okay she wants
to go as me she's trying to make a point
about blackface she wants to go as me
who's
i've never worn blackface unlike half of
hollywood and nbc
um but like why wouldn't she go as
justin trudeau why wouldn't she goes
jimmy kimmel why wouldn't she go as like
joy behar why would she go like those
people actually wore it so she's a
little off the mark to start with but
man she p she painted right now even she
was trying to make a she was trying to
make a far left wing point that was
false about you
and got and got eaten by the machine
just just as much so i thought that that
was a beautifully ironic
outcome to that particular scenario when
you talk about what's going to change
it seems to me that unfortunately it's
going to have to get worse before it
gets better
not because the left is going to stop
but just because the
the left is they found that the best
thing that they can do in order to gain
power
is to whine a lot and threaten a lot and
then corporations particularly
are so vulnerable to this sort of stuff
i mean just this week yelp decided that
they were going to change their policy
and so now if there is a complaint about
a restaurant that is reviewed by yelp
and somebody says a racist thing
happened
yelp will issue a warning on their
website
warning everybody like an abuse notice
on their website without any evidentiary
basis
that this place has been reported for
racist activity
and then they have a higher level where
if a media outlet reports the story
then they call it now a is something
like a confirmed incident
of racism even if it's just the outlet
reporting the allegation so we now have
major american companies
who have the lives of other companies in
their hands basically
being willing to throw out any
allegation whatsoever
by any rando i mean i think that until
the right gets as whiny as the left or
at least attempts to utilize its market
power in the same way as the left which
is something i don't actually want
uh then i think this is going to
continue because corporations have an
absolute interest
in catering to the whiniest among us i
and we have to somehow get through this
because
we believe in the first amendment in
this country and we believe in in saying
how we feel and having a diversity of
opinion
and when you get to tough issues being
able to discuss them that's
an american principle never before has
it been we have a new way of thinking
and you need to shut up
you need to not speak about it at all
you just accept my new way of thinking
or you're awful
period and canceled and maybe fired how
insane is that
you know we do need more corporations
with a backbone like i loved it when the
wall street journal
stood up to its employees who were like
throwing some fit about i don't know
maybe like a heather mcdonald op-ed or
some op-ed in uh
in their newspaper like it's not factual
and we shouldn't have done this and then
like there's 80 employees who were like
no
and the journal's like i understand
you're upset so anyway
that's what employers need to do truly
like
you understand you're in the business of
news of like journalism where we have to
cover facts and when we do opinions we
have to offer both sides and
it may upset you even in hiring for my
company now ben because i'm just
launching a new
company i'm like i'm talking to the
young people saying look
let's get this straight up front if you
are not in favor of the full
discussion like uncensored discussion of
some of the most comfortable
controversial things happening in the
country right now
you shouldn't work here if you're
somebody who needs five compliments
before i have to tell you what you did
wrong
you shouldn't work here you need me to
hold your hand when i tell you have to
work on a saturday
you shouldn't work here you're going to
be challenged you're going to be
intellectually stimulated you're going
to have fun you're going to learn you're
going to grow you're going to get
stronger
but it's not going to be easy right more
employers i think need to say that to
their employees as opposed to like
you're special you'll never be hurt your
feelings will never be hurt
and you can just go to your safe space
if anybody says anything that doesn't
completely comply with the way you want
it to be said
it's like i don't want to live in this
world i don't want my kids to have to
live in this world
so you're right we have to stand up and
fight because it used to just be
academia
and it crept into hollywood it took over
news
and now it's taken over corporate
america not to mention half of sports
and if the if it's not even just the
right because i know a lot of liberals
who are totally against this nonsense
you know you look at the harper's letter
but beyond that just like center left or
just quote unquote
regular progressives they don't like
this nonsense either it's this far left
contingent
that has the loudest voice in the room
and people are listening to them because
if you're the owner of a corporation and
somebody's running in there saying
racist racist racist and i'm hurt and
this is like i feel unsafe
and you make me unsafe if you don't you
know do what i'm asking you to do
they're like
oh my god people didn't used to drop
charges like that unless it was
really serious now it's morphed over
into you know
whatever you you come in work with the
black hat instead of the white hat and
somehow like you
you've hurt somebody you've made them
feel unsafe one of the things on that
front is i'm really interested to watch
what happens with joe rogan over at
spotify
right because you've already seen the
revolt of some of the spotify employees
against him
and he's basically like yeah too bad
pound sand
and so far spotify has had his back so
i really hope they stay steely spined
and continue to have his back and set a
lesson for other companies that
if you're going to be in the business of
especially of news and conversation you
have to be more open-minded
and even any other corporation needs to
stand up for what our american
principles are
this is not east germany so let's talk
about
you know what it's like to be a woman in
a position of high responsibility and
high power and high
visibility what do you think are sort of
the special challenges that women face
and
and when do you think that the
allegations of sexism and the
and the obstacles faced by women go too
far well i don't know if i can sum up
all the challenges women
face in you know a couple of sentences
but there's no question there are some
and
that's sort of what i'm seeing with the
racial discussion we're having now
there's no question there are still
racists here in the united states
but i don't believe this is a racist
country and i feel the same about sexism
there's no question that there are
sexists
here in the united states but we're not
a sexist country at all
so you have to deal with it on a
case-by-case basis but i would say in
general you know men control most halls
of power
most of the corporations they still
control most political bodies and that
does pose certain challenges for women
that we have to figure out how to
handle the vice presidential debate was
interesting because i do think and the
studies do show that women get
interrupted more than men
like at the board room the men will
interrupt women more than they'll
interrupt a man speaking and um
i've actually in the past been a big
advocate and remain one of that the
tactics she used which is just hand up
i'm speaking
and it does make people stop talking
stop interrupting you but she overused
it and it was obviously a tactic and she
used it in a way
when it's a debate the guy's allowed to
jump in on the tail end of your thought
that's what a debate is it's not like
you're in front of a company
saying this is how i'm going to handle
this situation and all these guys are
trying to jump in that's when you're
like yo
not done she's in a debate like they
over-corrected for what happened at the
first presidential debate like i wanted
to hear more back and forth it was too
antiseptic
and looking now you should have the two
minutes and now you shall have the two
minutes like
it they did i i have a lot of thoughts
about the debates but
i'll say this about being a strong woman
woman you have to do it you have to do
it unapologetically
and that leads to some consternation in
certain circles people aren't
necessarily looking at it as a strong
woman who's unapologetic about it
in a way that's favorable and i think
that's led to
some problems in my own life um
however i my own approach to all of that
has always been to not
boo and who and whine about it just be
better just
keep going just work harder and you know
now you'll get to like oh
that's a sexist comment like screw you
you don't understand what most women are
up against well i think i understand
pretty well
you know i didn't come from some fancy
powerful family with
big connections i'm self-made entirely
and so
i do understand i understand how to get
through a sexist encounter
how to you know sort of as i said the
other day
woman up be my strongest self and handle
handle tough circumstances i i don't
believe
in the constant resort to victimization
i've been victimized again
i don't like identity politics i don't
like how people are making our lady
parts what we're all supposed to be
about
or the people who want to make
somebody's pigmentation what they're all
about
it's just it's it's completely
disrespectful and diminishing
um there was one day at the in the obama
years where they invited
like female reporters to come to the
white house for like woman's day and i
was like you know what
i'll go to the white house when i get
invited as a reporter
that's when i'll go i don't want to go
because i'm getting like you know i'm
getting to check the box of
being you know having the right
genitalia so i get to go to the wise
no i'm good you call me when you want me
for my brain not for my lady parts
um and i just think we're getting away
from that now it's just such a rush
towards identity politics and
victimization and finding your posse
who's also been victimized
and people think it's empowerment and
it's exactly the opposite it's
disempowerment so let's talk about the
debates for a second since you mentioned
them and since you've moderated the
presidential debates
uh maybe you can evaluate how you think
the debate moderators have performed
thus far and it seems like obviously
chris wallace had a tougher job
considering the
behavior during that debate uh susan
page had a much easier job considering
that that was one of the
more as you mentioned polite and
antiseptic debates i've ever seen on
national television how do you think the
moderators are doing
i think susan page did fine you know it
was boring um
personally i'm in favor of a spicier
debate that's just my own approach to it
but um
and it was boring but fair i didn't
think she was unfair i went back and
looked at the whole transcript of every
question she asked and i was like it's
fine it's right down the middle you know
her topic selection probably leaned more
left than if you had you know fox news
anchor doing it but that's okay that's
whatever
people are used to that it wasn't
egregious um
chris wallace he had a tough time and uh
you know
i don't know if he had planned for it
i'm surprised actually because when we
prepared for our debates at fox we used
to have
discussions about especially with trump
what if he won't shut up
what if he tries to run over us what if
he won't stop interrupting like
we talked about all of that and we came
up with game plans so i don't know
if he didn't do that or if it was just
at a level he
you know had never anticipated um i
happened i happened to
to believe in cutting the mics and i
think i wouldn't have been associated
with a debate
that didn't let me as the moderator
control the cameras and the mics
because you wouldn't believe how fast
they stopped talking when you you take
back control of the camera on you
and the mics on you then they will stop
talking
quickly and you only have to do it once
you know like
like being a parent you know you got to
like show your kid you mean the threat
one time
and then they behave so as long as you
follow through with your threat
then every other time the rest of the
debate would have been much better
especially with trump if he knew he was
going to lose the camera and lose his
mic
he he would have been more reasonable
and then and then you go from there then
then it's a judgment call you can't cut
the guy off at every turn
you want to see him going back and forth
that's that's a highlight of a debate
um so i don't know i i love it's for me
it's frustrating because i'd love to get
out there and do it myself but uh not
this go around
yeah what what do you um make of the the
complaints that i've
put out there that there's too much
emphasis on trying to get a
quote-unquote objective journalist doing
the actual debate questions that frankly
i'd rather see a debate moderated by
sean hannity and rachel maddow then
watch the debate moderated by susan page
because at least you know you're going
to get the harshest version of
like just have shawn question joe biden
and have rachel maddow
question donald trump and i think that'd
be way more interesting and way more
entertaining
i'm against that as somebody who's in
the middle you know i don't want that
um because i'm going to select myself
right out of the running but i
understand the point and i actually
think um
maybe the solution is to have like a
three-person panel where you have sort
of a straight news journalist who
is you know objectively straight news
not don lemon right somebody who's
actually straight news
um there's still a few of us out there
and then
pundits you know from either side but
the question is would you have would you
have hannity question
biden or would you have him question
trump i think you'd have to have a
question biden right
and then you'd have maddow question
trump
um and see how they do i think it'd be
interesting i think it'd be
absolute war at the anchor desk but it'd
be interesting
so in just one second i want to ask you
about how you balanced all of this with
family you mentioned family before and
being a mom
and i want to hear about your
perspective on balancing career and
family because i think one of the great
lies of the 20th century
is that everybody can have it all and
obviously you have to find that balance
but if you want to hear megan kelly's
answers you have to be a daily wire
member head on over to dailywire.com
click join at the top of the page you
can hear the rest of our conversation
over there megyn kelly it's always great
to talk to you and of course
go listen to the megan kelly show over
at devil maycare media
make sure to check it out megan thanks
so much for joining us really appreciate
it
thanks ben lots of love
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel wydowski
associate producer nick sheehan our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nichols audio is mixed
by mike coromina hair and makeup is by
nika geneva title graphics are by
cynthia angulo the ben shapiro show
sunday special is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2020.
[Music]